Creo que además de cuán bueno uno es ahora,
lo más importante es lo bueno que uno puede llegar a ser.
Estaba visitando este centro de maternidad en el norte de India.
Estaba observando a las parteras,
y me di cuenta de que podía ver en ellas una forma extrema de este gran esfuerzo
que es cómo la gente mejora al encontrarse con dificultades...
o no.
Estas mujeres tienen hijos en una región
donde el centro de maternidad típico tiene una mortalidad de 1 de cada 20 bebés
y las mamás mueren a un ritmo diez veces mayor que en otros lugares.
Conocemos desde hace décadas las prácticas esenciales
que detienen a los causantes de muertes en los partos,
y el asunto es que incluso aquí...
en este lugar especialmente,
las cosas más simples no son simples.
Sabemos, por ejemplo, que debemos lavarnos las manos y usar guantes limpios,
pero aquí,
el grifo está en otra sala,
y no tienen guantes limpios.
Reutilizan sus guantes,
lavándolos en este recipiente con lejía diluida,
pero, como pueden ver, todavía hay sangre en los guantes, del último parto.
Un 10 % de los bebés nacen con dificultades para respirar en cualquier lugar.
Sabemos qué hacer.
Limpiamos al bebé con un paño limpio para estimularlo, para que respire.
Si no empieza a respirar,
le aspiramos sus vías respiratorias.
Y si eso no funciona, le damos aire con la máscara para bebés.
Pero estas son destrezas que han aprendido principalmente de los libros de texto,
y esa máscara para bebé está rota.
Esta fotografía, muy perturbadora
es una imagen que nos permite comprender lo grave que es la situación.
Es un bebé a los 10 minutos de nacer,
y está vivo,
pero apenas.
No hay un paño limpio,
no lo han secado,
no ha tenido calor de piel con piel,
y tiene una pinza sin esterilizar en el cordón.
Está por ocurrir una infección,
y está perdiendo su temperatura minuto a minuto.
Un parto exitoso requiere un equipo de gente eficaz.
Todos deben estar capacitados y coordinados;
los enfermeros que llevan a cabo los partos en estos lugares,
el médico que los respalda,
el empleado responsable de que los 22 fármacos vitales y los suministros
estén en el depósito y la lado de la cama,
la médica oficial a cargo,
responsable de la calidad de todo el edificio.
Ellos son todos profesionales con experiencia.
No conocí a nadie que no hubiera estado en miles de partos.
Pero frente a las dificultades con las que se encuentran,
parecen estar al límite.
Ya no estaban mejorando.
Lo que realmente importa es lo bueno que uno puede llegar a ser.
Lo que obliga a una pregunta fundamental:
¿Cómo pueden mejorar los profesionales en lo que hacen?
¿Cómo logran ser geniales?
Hay dos puntos de vista sobre esto:
Una es la visión pedagógica tradicional
en la que uno va a la escuela,
estudia, practica, aprende, se gradúa
y, luego, sale al mundo
y se abre camino solo.
Un profesional es alguien capaz de manejar su propio perfeccionamiento.
Prácticamente todos los profesionales se han formado bajo esta perspectiva.
Así aprenden los médicos,
los abogados,
los científicos...
los músicos.
Y funciona.
Consideren por ejemplo a la legendaria instructora de violín Dorothy DeLay.
Ella entrenó a un listado increíble de virtuosos del violín:
Midori, Sarah Chang, Itzhak Perlman.
Cada uno llegó a ella como un talento joven,
y todos trabajaron con ella durante años.
Según ella, de lo que más se ocupó
fue de inculcarles el hábito de pensar y de aprender
para que pudieran abrirse camino en el mundo sin ella
cuando estuvieran listos.
Ahora bien, un punto de vista opuesto proviene de los deportes.
Ellos dicen: "Nunca terminas,
todo el mundo necesita un entrenador".
Todo el mundo.
El más grande en el mundo necesita un entrenador.
Y traté de pensar en esto como cirujano.
Pagarle a alguien para que viniera al quirófano,
me observara y me criticara.
Parece absurdo.
Ser un experto implica que uno no necesita ser guiado.
¿Cuál postura es la correcta?
Sé que el entrenamiento personal en el deporte fue una idea estadounidense.
En 1875,
Harvard y Yale jugaron uno de los primeros partidos de fútbol americano.
Yale contrató a un entrenador titular;
Harvard no lo hizo.
¿Cuál fue el resultado?
Durante los siguientes 30 años,
Harvard solo ganó cuatro veces.
Harvard contrató a un entrenador.
(Risas)
Y ahora este es el modo en el que funciona el deporte.
Pero, entonces, ¿es necesario?
¿Se transfiere eso a otras áreas?
De entre toda la gente, decidí preguntarle
a Itzhak Perlman.
Él había entrenado al modo Dorothy DeLay
y sin duda se transformó en el mejor violinista de su generación.
Una de las cosas buenas de escribir para "The New Yorker"
es que llamo por teléfono a la gente y ellos me responden.
(Risas)
Y Perlman me devolvió el llamado.
Y terminamos teniendo una charla de casi dos horas
sobre cómo consiguió llegar a ser lo que es en su carrera.
Y le pregunté: "¿Por qué los violinistas no tienen entrenadores?"
Y me dijo: "No lo sé,
pero yo siempre lo tuve".
"¿Siempre has tenido un entrenador?"
"Oh, sí, mi esposa, Toby".
Ellos se habían graduado juntos en el conservatorio Juilliard,
y ella había renunciado a su trabajo como violinista de concierto
para ser su entrenadora,
sentada en la audiencia,
observándolo y dándole su opinión:
"Itzahk, en esa parte del medio,
has sonado un poquito mecánico, ¿sabes?
¿Qué podrías hacer distinto la próxima?"
Según él, esto fue crucial para lo que llegó a ser.
Parece que hay numerosos problemas en lograr las cosas solo.
Uno no reconoce los problemas que se interponen en el camino
o si lo hace,
no siempre sabe cómo resolverlos.
Y el resultado es que en alguna parte del camino,
uno deja de mejorar.
Y pensé en eso,
y me di cuenta de que era exactamente lo que me había pasado como cirujano.
Empecé a ejercer en el 2003,
y durante los primeros años
iba mejorando continuamente, con una curva de aprendizaje hacia arriba.
Observé como mi índice de complicaciones había disminuido de un año a otro.
Y después de unos cinco años,
se nivelaron.
Y unos años después de esto,
me di cuenta de que ya no estaba mejorando.
Y pensé: "¿Es esto lo mejor que voy a llegar a ser?"
Y pensé un poquito más y me dije:
"Bien,
probaré un entrenador".
Y se lo pedí a un antiguo profesor mío que ya estaba jubilado,
se llama Bob Osteen,
y él aceptó venir al quirófano
y observarme.
El caso...
recuerdo ese primer caso.
Fue muy bien.
No pensé que hubiera mucho que tuviera para decirme
cuando habíamos terminado.
En cambio, él tenía una página entera llena de notas.
(Risas)
"Solo pequeñeces", me dijo.
Pero son las pequeñas cosas las que importan.
"¿Has notado que la luz se salió del alcance de la herida
durante el procedimiento?
Estuviste una media hora
solo operando con la luz que reflejaban las superficies".
"Otra cosa que noté", me dijo,
"es que, de vez en cuando, tus codos se van muy arriba en el aire.
Eso significa que no tienes todo el control.
Los codos de un cirujano deben estar bajos descansando cómodamente a los costados.
Y eso significa que si sientes que tus codos se suben,
debes usar un instrumento diferente, o solo mover los pies".
Fue otro nivel diferente de conciencia.
Y tuve que pensar,
saben, había algo muy profundo en todo esto.
Él estaba describiendo lo que hacen los grandes entrenadores;
ellos son nuestros ojos y oídos externos,
nos brindan una imagen más precisa de la realidad.
Reconocen los aspectos básicos.
Desglosan nuestras acciones
y nos ayudan a reconstruirlas de nuevo.
Después de dos meses de esta asesoría,
empecé a sentir que estaba mejorando de nuevo.
Y después de un año,
vi como mis complicaciones disminuían aún más.
Fue doloroso.
No me gusta que me observen,
y por momentos no quería trabajar para mejorar las cosas.
También sentí que había períodos en los que empeoraba en vez de mejorar.
Pero me hizo comprender
que los entrenadores hacían algo profundamente importante.
En mi otro trabajo
lidero un centro de innovación de sistemas de salud llamado Ariadne Labs,
donde nos ocupamos de los problemas en la provisión de atención médica
incluyendo los partos mundiales.
Como parte de eso,
hemos trabajado con la OMS
haciendo una lista para partos seguros.
Establece los aspectos fundamentales.
Desglosa las reglas básicas...
las acciones esenciales que un equipo debe seguir
cuando una mujer está en trabajo de parto,
cuando está lista para pujar,
cuando el bebé ya está afuera,
y cuando la mamá y el bebé ya pueden volver a casa.
Y sabíamos
que con solo entregar una lista no cambiaríamos mucho,
y que incluso el enseñar en un aula no necesariamente sería suficiente
para que la gente hiciera los cambios necesarios para hacerlo realidad.
Y pensé en mi experiencia y dije:
"¿Y si usamos entrenadores?
¿Y si usáramos entrenadores a gran escala?
Encontramos unos socios increíbles,
incluyendo al gobierno de India,
e hicimos una prueba allí en 120 centros de maternidad,
en Uttar Pradesh, el estado más grande de India.
A la mitad de los centros básicamente solo los observamos,
pero la otra mitad recibió la visita de unos entrenadores.
Entrenamos a un ejército de médicos y enfermeras como esta
que aprendieron a respetar el tratamiento, y también a los directivos,
y les ayudamos a desarrollar sus puntos fuertes
y a combatir sus debilidades.
Por ejemplo, una de las cosas que debieron trabajar con la gente
--y resultó ser algo muy importante--
fue la comunicación.
Lograr que los enfermeros hablen sin rodeos si la máscara de bebé está rota
o no hay guantes en el almacén
o alguien no se lava las manos.
Y lograr que los otros, incluso los directivos,
aprendan a escuchar.
Este pequeño ejército de instructores terminó entrenando a 400 enfermeros
y otros asistentes de partos,
y a 100 médicos y directores.
Supervisamos los resultados de 160 000 nacimientos.
Los resultados:
en el grupo de control teníamos
--estos son los que no recibieron entrenamiento--
cumplieron con solo un tercio de las prácticas básicas
que estábamos evaluando.
Y lo más destacado durante los años del estudio
fue que con el tiempo no vimos ningún avance.
La otra gente recibió cuatro meses de entrenamiento
y otros ocho meses con una frecuencia más baja,
y los vimos aumentar
sus logros en más de dos tercios de las prácticas.
Funciona.
Pudimos ver como mejoró la calidad
y esto se ha verificado en una amplia gama de clínicas
lo que nos indicó que el entrenamiento puede ser un buen modo
de agregar valor a lo que hacemos.
Imaginen todas las categorías laborales a las que podría extenderse en el mundo,
y que millones de personas podrían realizar.
Pero claramente estábamos en los comienzos,
porque aún había un lago camino por recorrer.
Debemos elaborar un listado
para alcanzar una reducción importante de la mortalidad.
Pero empezamos a ver los primeros lugares que lo estaban logrando,
y este centro fue uno de ellos
porque el entrenamiento los ayudó a cumplir con las cosas fundamentales.
Y lo pueden ver aquí.
Esta es una mujer de 23 años
que llegó en ambulancia,
con trabajo de parto de su tercer hijo.
Rompió aguas en la zona de primeros auxilios,
por lo que la llevaron directamente a la sala de partos,
y entonces le hicieron los controles.
Aquí puse un indicador de tiempo
así pueden ver lo rápido que pasa esto
y cómo hace más complicadas las cosas.
En cuatro minutos
le tomaron la presión arterial, le tomaron el pulso
y controlaron la frecuencia cardíaca del bebé.
Esto significa que el tensiómetro y el monitor fetal Doppler
estaban allí, y la enfermera sabía cómo usarlos.
El equipo estaba capacitado y coordinado.
La mamá estaba bien,
el ritmo cardíaco del bebé era 143, lo normal.
Ocho minutos después, la intensidad de las contracciones aumentó,
por lo que la enfermera se lavó las manos,
se puso guantes limpios,
la examinó, y encontró que su cérvix estaba totalmente dilatada.
El bebé estaba listo para nacer.
Entonces pasó directamente a realizar la siguiente serie de controles.
Examinó todo el equipo
y se aseguró de tener todo lo necesario junto a la cama:
la máscara de bebé, la toalla esterilizada,
el instrumental esterilizado que necesitaba.
Y luego, tres minutos más tarde, un pujo y el bebé estaba afuera.
(Aplausos)
Estaba observando este parto,
y de pronto noté que los ánimos en esa habitación habían cambiado.
La enfermera miraba a la agente comunitaria de salud
que había venido con la mujer
porque esa bebé no parecía estar viva.
Estaba azul, flácida, y no respiraba.
Sería el uno en ese 'uno de cada veinte'.
Pero la enfermera continuó con los controles.
Secó a la bebé con una toalla seca.
Y después de un minuto, cuando eso no estimuló a la bebé,
corrió a agarrar la máscara de bebés
y la otra fue a hacer la aspiración.
No tenía aspirador mecánico porque no podía contar con la electricidad,
así que usó uno bucal
y en 20 segundos
ya estaba despejando las vías respiratorias de la niñita.
Y obtuvo un líquido verde espeso,
y dentro del minuto de estar haciendo eso
y aspirando una y otra vez,
la bebé empezó a respirar.
(Aplausos)
Otro minuto, y la bebé estaba llorando.
Y cinco minutos más tarde,
estaba rosada y entrando en calor sobre el pecho de su madre,
y esa madre se estiró para agarrar la mano de la enfermera,
y todas pudieron respirar tranquilas.
Vi a un equipo transformado gracias al entrenamiento.
Y vi que por lo menos una vida se había salvado gracias a eso.
Unos meses después nos pusimos en contacto con esa madre.
La mamá y la bebé estaban muy bien.
El nombre de la bebé es Hansika.
Significa "hermosa" en hindi.
Y ella representa lo que es posible
cuando realmente entendemos
cómo la gente puede mejorar en lo que hace.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)